cents is a really fun topic I really
quite enjoy hope you'll enjoy it by the
end too however if there's one thing
I've learned from teaching senior
students and seeing their understanding
of this having come from having
developed that under 1089 and u10 here's
the thing which I've become I've become
really frustrated seeing but I realize
why it happens okay
many students in year 11 and 12 they get
quite good at working with these things
and doing the skills that I'm gonna
teach you over the next week and a half
sort of when I say sorta I mean they get
really fast at it they sort of can do it
almost without thinking it becomes like
an automatic fluent thing however they
often do it without really getting
what's going on underneath so therefore
they make errors of conceptual
understanding that's what we say they
can do the process but if I ask them why
they like more auto because I did
exercises on this in year 10 and and I
got the right answers repeatedly so
that's it isn't it
there are lots of students who know the
they know the rules but they don't know
why any of the rules are what they are
ok now this is what you need to have
your pens out of your hands for to hear
if all you end up doing at it is topic
is knowing the rules really well and
being very fast and accurate at doing
them if that's all you're doing then
you're just being a machine you're not
being a mathematician like that's what
we have these things for right these
things don't need to understand they
just need to give us accurate answers
and give it to us fast okay but I have
no intention to make you a calculator
because calculators are better
calculating that you are you know a
calculators used to be people like that
was a profession it was a job it's like
a what do you do I'm a calculator
because we didn't have these things so
if we wanted to do things accurately
like work out how fast and at what angle
do you need to go so you hit the moon in
three days you need some really accurate
numbers right so we hired people they
were calculated and then these got
invented they are really small and now
you can buy them really cheap ok since
we have those I don't want to turn you
guys into those I need you to be a
father I need you
disdain what is going on okay so I'm
gonna ask you to think really hard in
this lesson and over the next week and a
half as we try to understand this pens
in hand the first thing we're gonna look
at is I saw it's mostly come from well
they all come from roots and cube roots
and etc but most of them are square
roots square roots come up walks like in
Pythagoras right so we need to
understand how square roots and square e
relate to each other let's start with a
simple table AJ if I took a number like
say root fine this is a sir it's
somewhere between root for and root 9 so
it's like two point something
I have no idea what something it is but
that's the point it's a certain and we
just have some we'd decimal stuff now
root 5 is some number if you square it
because root 5 is the number that you
square to get 5 well if I square that I
should get five right so squaring and
taking the square root are kind of like
undoing each other all right we actually
have a special name for this I want you
to write these down squaring and taking
the square root but BC inverted commas
I'll explain why later on they call it
inverses you actually know lots of
inverses already addition and
subtraction are inverses right yet add 3
is something you take away 3 you'll land
back on your original number what are
the inverses do you know about not just
adding and subtracting there is
multiplying and dividing there they're
opposites of each other they read us
what's happening so we call them
inverses okay so I can generalize this
this is an example but over here on the
right-hand side if you have a like a
different color or something like that I
can say generally speaking that if you
have a square root of any number X and
then you square that thing
right then that should land you back on
X does that make sense
hurry I'm putting the brackets I mean I
would say like 90% of the brackets I
have a place in my working or on the
board just to make things clear it's not
because they have to be there but
because I want to be unambiguous in what
I'm communicating to you guys
basically what I'm try to avoid is the
confusion between this and this because
they're different okay so are you
supporting whole thing or you spray
anything inside and I don't want you to
mix up the two so this is squaring the
whole thing does that make sense
okay so this is the first thing I want
to know put your pins down again for a
second remember we've got that adding
and subtracting right if you've got a
number like say actually will go in X
because I just wrote out the add five
and then you take away five because I
said these are inverses right what will
the answer be so just the X now does it
matter whether I by this time I added in
there as subtractive does it matter what
order I do it in yes
so I'm gonna start with the same number
again instead of adding and then
subtracting I'm going to subtract and
then I'm going to add it and sure enough
you still get X okay you'll notice the
same thing with multiplication and
division if you multiply by five 10
divided by 5 doesn't matter if you
switch that around you'll still end up
where you started agree okay keep that
in your mind let's think again of
another example so underneath you
example instead of taking the square
root of five and then squaring what if
this is the example storymap thought
what if I Square first and then take the
square root okay now let's not do this
in our heads we can do this ourselves
like manually I can work out that thing
on the other side first which is 25 and
the number that you square to get 25 is
of course on cool so it seems like I've
gotten back where I started
right like I said I started with five
yeah I squared it then I took the square
root which is the reverse order
yeah so a little it looks great at the
moment right everything looks fine and
many people stop there and then talk
about this they write this on the right
hand side is there room right there
right the square root of a square number
is that all you started with okay that's
what a lot of people say that's what I'm
gonna love it you're 11 and 12 students
believe but it's not true let me
convince me
I'm gonna give you a different on the
phone this time I'm going to give you
negative five and that gets squared and
then you take square root okay now again
think this through with me a step at a
time
as with all brackets and operations you
start from the inside the deepest part
and then your work outputs yeah so
negative five all square is negative
five times negative five degree let's
write that just for the sake of I'd only
miss anything you find times negative
five yes
now there's two negatives under that
what happens when you multiply it well
they are going to become a positive so
they become a positive four fives then
become twenty-five don't they okay so
let's just finish write the square root
25 I already worked out what that was
you told me what it was it's mine
okay what the Dickens is going on okay
because apparently this is not true
right look look at this third example I
started with negative five I did
something and then I undid it and I did
it can't back to negative five did I
write in fact that I got somewhere else
okay what's happening in why I mean
okay the short answer is no and that's
why this answer here is fine I will come
to that I promise I'll come to that but
but not yet okay just look at my working
I've um I started with the question and
then I did one two three lines of
working are there any problems with any
of the lights look carefully at them
does it look okay you need to convince
yourself not because I tell you because
if what tells me
does it look convincing to you
just cuz I could hit okay so now that
I've let you sit and think for a moment
let me tell you there is nothing wrong
with what you've written down okay now
which I said from the beginning but I
made you doubt it didn't I okay now
here's the issue here's why this is not
always true the very first thing we did
was squaring do you remember that we had
to deal with the square first before you
could touch the square root but when you
square a number right if you square a
negative number then what you get on the
next line kind of it doesn't remember
whether you started with a negative or
not did you notice by the time I got to
this line it looked exactly like this
okay so how'd I am and I like
accidentally poured water over my own
piece of paper and then you could read
this part it was born right and this is
the final lines of my working okay you
don't really know what came before did
you notice that because squaring it kind
of removes that information out right is
that when you plus or minus before oh I
don't know it's gone now
and you can't tell there's no way to
tell squaring is kind of like a trapdoor
once you fall through you can't get back
and find out what was going on earlier
that information about plus or minus is
gone forever
okay so just bring it back as a result
as a result in age you can write this
sometimes though that's what he tempted
to is about yeah like it works sometimes
what was the difference between the two
and three it was the negative side right
so this is true now you can write it let
me tell you when it's true when X is not
negative it's being negative that mocks
up with this right so in other words if
X is greater than zero does it work for
x equals zero
is it true if x equals zero yeah zero
squared is zero the square root of that
is still zero so it does work so I can
say greater than or equal to okay it
does include zero but if X is negative
you're in trouble something else happens
and you have to be careful that a lot of
people just ignore that they just
they're just sort of like that okay but
please this is really an important what
a beep highlighting colored box around
it it matters